me and just completely took over the
game and dominated the game
and those are special players who have
the ability to do that in derrick rose
was that and has become that watch out
thomas bryant got fouled hard by blake
griffin now he goes back at him
and griffin is just smiling
and bryant not happy but he's got to
calm down
emotional right now talk about the
potential to make money we don't want to
lose money
the officials will get together there's
going to be a technical foul
[Applause]
that was the first bump and then blake
kind of throwing to the ground and
[Music]
jonathan sterling tried to get in the
middle of it
thomas bryant wanted the action though
[Applause]
yeah that was a little cheap shot by
blake griffin but i mean that's what
happens in this game
it was gonna be some ticky tack
[Applause]
tactile touch i mean i mean thomas
i don't know hopefully he's in the game
still that's what i'm thinking too
you could see jonathan sterling trying
to calm down and thomas bryant touched
him
and that's when sterling was said whoa
[Applause]
i'm thomas bryant he's an emotional
player i love that don't change that
about yourself but
the emotional in the right spots the
right time of the game
and yeah that was a cheap shot by blake
griffin but how do you handle it
right you know you got to handle that
throughout the game later on
watch watch watch how the referee
jonathan sterling gets in the middle and
[Applause]
i don't think it's right here i think
now is when it happens
see how he's going back at the referee
right there that's where it could be a
problem
early on when there was contact you kind
of don't know what's going on